mrs. Sarah from New Jersey I was
wondering if you could please stop
allowing Benji to derail the
conversation like this my fault me the
Gary Letterman wants to come in and
comment he thinks that you guys are
being insanely unfair to Kavanaugh I'm
not being unfair I don't know a thing
about it
we're just talking like everybody else
is talking I didn't want Ben G in here
guys
it's too late I mean leave okay all
right fine jela Gary yes - it why do you
agree I didn't agree
I never said yes Benji was here he was
in he just walked in you allow him to do
that but Gary's the keeper of the gate
he linemen why don't you call Gary on
the wrap-up show maybe I need to shake a
finger at Gary come on that's my point
should Gary be the keeper of the gate is
the question you're asking because my
mat told me and he thinks he should be
the keeper of he wants to apply for
Gary's job in terms of who gets in the
room he feels he's better judge why two
weeks what if he's better than you what
is are you insulted by the Met pitching
me privately about wanting to be the
keeper the gate insulted knows I'm
surprised that a guy that's been here
for a very short time thinks he can
understand you better than someone who's
been here for over 35 years
listen nobody nobody's going to be
perfect at keeping the gate the mistakes
will be made but I always opt to try to
do my very best and I thought that Benji
bringing as a penny today might be
interesting I'm a man I know you have
said to me that you would be better at
keeping the gate what is your theory and
would you have let Benji in this morning
it's not about that Gary's bad I just
think that I would be very very good at
it I better than Gary I bring a
different energy right it's a young
energy a younger energy you're using the
age rap yes I know that's age
discrimination no no it's it's I'm sure
when Gary what about the fact that what
about the fact that Gary has known me a
long time should that enter into it you
make the argument that for example
Letterman switched producers and keepers
of the gate and stuff regularly
they switch it regularly I saw we saw
like Colbert this week my parents were
in town and in the commercials he has a
young guy like me he Huddle's up with
you know are you are you saying you're
more ambitious and hungry than Gary
definitely I mean Howard can I ask a
question please yes I think that men
that probably does have a good idea of
what's funny for the show but can he
handle the pressure of Manning the gate
ah that's a good question go ahead okay
fair enough go ahead my man no no that
didn't at one time I got a little upset
and yes like this is a job interview
right now I want to hear why you would
be better than Gary I mean I can give
you a million different go ahead I'll go
down that'll be your top ten and again
this isn't I'm not saying Gary is bad
I'm saying I'm good okay all right go
ahead I work more for less I'm cheaper
I'm more economical you know what I mean
are you saying fire Gary get rid of Gary
we don't save any money well let's see
how the trial goes okay I see how the
trial goes go ahead uh you know I've
demonstrated leadership ability with the
staff I well that's because I don't have
power if I power I mean they'll be able
to feel Gary still has his heart in the
game anybody who's been doing this 30
years it's hard to have the same fire as
you do on day one then with in with that
thinking you would think our doesn't
have a heart the game oh I don't I can
only tell you that Howard's on a
different plane I am on I am on a
different plane point number four again
these people are on a different plane
we're talking talent you know what I'm
saying that that would mean that that
you don't think much of me give me your
best point in the middle and why you
should replace Gary as the keeper of the
gate go ahead I carefully listen to the
show same IQ as Gary yes all right
better education go ahead better college
that's true
are you looking for free tickets or chat
our parties to schmooze at I'm not
I'm not a big concert or go out guy
would you have let Benji in this morning
I would not have what based on what
based on the fact that he didn't really
have a a cogent point that he wanted to
quickly make that he could have come in
here delivered it and want you to hear a
funny angle and that would be probably
the correct thing to do I'm ed says
Benji Howard was having a lot of fun
this morning it's not so easy to throw
Benji I would never call an underling
emojis like flypaper
oh listen shower do you have any more
questions thank you for taking my time
for taking my question I do appreciate
that Howard one of the things I like
about him that is his throat is always
clear he never clears his throat in
front of me that I will give them you
are you talking about my Matt taking
over all of Gary's know just as keepers
oh you are you're pitching the whole
game I say what do we have to lose if
you take over
let me trail him for two weeks go ahead
and I do a great job yeah what the hell
what have we lost if I do a horrible job
what have we lost nothing I mean if you
can't handle the pressure listening to
him cry we'll be good radio they make a
point big blue the Yankees would first
place where was the first place so if we
let somebody able to manage the team for
two weeks what do we lose we lose we
lose our juice for those being number
one and he still hosts the wrap-up show
or does he have to give that up too if
you were well he could probably answer
phone calls or something speed phone
calls I would like his going he's gonna
be a screener an advisory role while
we're transitioning I say sure you would
even take over his role on the wrap-up I
could I'm prepared to do you have a
sense of history that carry us
absolutely I know all about the show I'm
very passionate that's what I'm saying
on day one you got someone who's gonna
show up you know before anybody else
there you go anybody else all right
thank you my let's try it all right Gary
there it is mom are you doing
you would